there is so much going on in the world
okay the banks are failing I found this
out this morning there's a meteor that
has a 1 in 560 chance of hitting Earth
in 2040. people are in Dire Straits
they're stressed out of their mind their
kids won't stop talking and they need a
little bit of relief and that's what
we're here to do we're here to provide
that peace that Tranquility that breath
in breath out for you with a little bit
of satisfaction I think you're right
people need satisfying renders and we're
we're going to give them to you
[Music]
Wes what do you find satisfying visually
oddly auditory
sonically like like your Tick Tock yeah
[Music]
big big Tick Tock star yeah I mean that
stupid little video I made got 200
million views on Tick Tock the
satisfying puzzle piece
it was the slide in and it I like that
do it again
I feel like for a lot of creative things
you know you're you're only competing
against your previous self but for this
one we're competing against Ren that's
the best best thing you've ever done and
for all of us we could still achieve
that and fall short of the glory of what
Ren's already done but Ren Ren can only
achieve that if he beats his past self
have you become worse as an artist Ren
hmm
okay so some ground rules we have a few
days here to finish this render looping
is a requirement sound design you gotta
do sound design
let's not make any Pixar films
I would never do anything like that and
finish it ah man
well okay I mean I thought I was gonna
have more time
to do it and you're like I'm gonna make
a movie release the Peter cut yes
beginning of Monday right now we got the
rest of this week to finish this stuff
let's meet back up on Friday and satisfy
each other
[Applause]
foreign
satisfaction to me I feel like it comes
down to The Usual Suspects right it's
the color it's the sound it's the design
the loop ability all very important and
for me I like machines that make things
and break things or just do things in a
seamless Loop mechanically and perfectly
I thought there was a machine that could
perfectly create and destroy gold hot
liquid molten gold into this orb and it
hardens you hear the freezing the
crackling the satisfying the release of
the pressure from inside as the machine
opens up revealing your new golden orb
but
what fun is gold when it's not shared
cut right down the middle with a laser
melting ooh gooey down the middle and
slides down two sides of the ramp two
steel cut blades
come out from the sides angle down and
scrape the remaining gold away right in
your bank account that's satisfying to
me not real gold we should add a
disclaimer I'm not sending you real gold
or even fake gold it's not Bitcoin
either it actually has no value
should we do an nft there's actually a
lot to unpack in the week that we have
you know the first thing I need to do is
build a machine right I need to build an
actual orb capsule that can open and
close with mechanical arms I need to
design an environment with the sliding
ramps with trap doors for the laser to
come through the actual laser itself the
tube system that's going to be pouring
the liquid there's also the simulation
side which is what so far has taken the
longest you need smoke simulations for
when the capsule opens you know the
pressure release you really want to feel
that when the laser is cutting through
the gold that is actually creating some
smoke as well all of these are different
simulations and then of course you have
my favorite simulation in this whole
piece which is the solid gold turning
into liquid again so obviously you guys
know there's different types of
simulations right there's particle
simulations which you see with Sparks
and confetti or or you know little
little particles that can fly all around
and they don't have to interact with
each other it's totally fine that they
pass through each other because there's
so many there's also the volume
simulations that you're very familiar
with from any explosions any you know
smoke simulations any real pyro
simulation anything with volume that is
moving and emulating the motion of smoke
flip is essentially the combination of
the two flip is the idea of taking your
particles and transferring them into the
volume World kind of like The Wraith
World in Shadow of Mordor or in Lord of
the Rings in general right you're seeing
things that don't exist on the physical
plane when the particles move into the
volume World they suddenly become aware
of their neighbors and their neighbor's
velocities now the point of a flip Sim
is to achieve what's called
non-divergence which is just a fancy
word that means flow direction we don't
want to flow into each other that's not
how Rivers work rivers meet and then the
area of least pressure that's where it
flows for this one I started with a very
very high viscosity so it's almost like
a solid and as the laser is going
through I'm procedurally telling Houdini
hey wherever this laser interacts with
the points in that area reduce their
viscosity from a million to one and what
that's doing is as the laser is moving
through this ball it is literally
changing the viscosity attribute of the
points which is causing them to fall
down now I could go in about foot fluids
for an hour and that's why I did there's
a literal hour tutorial on
coordinigital.com that breaks down one
of the liquid simulations from this
satisfying render it's a Houdini
tutorial but I believe that the core
concept of Flip Flip fluids is universal
learn a little bit about that and the
world will be yours so check it out on
the website if it sounds interesting to
you or if you just kind of into this
moment right now we can have more of a
moment in private on the website so the
concept for my satisfying render came
from being at a Christmas party where
there was a pool table and a buddy of
mine just pulled off this awesome shot
where we got like a whole bunch of the
balls in at once and the sound it made
that crack breaking the triangle and
there's something so satisfying about a
trick shot as we learned from Jordan
Island failing against Jake
that really just inspired me I was like
I wonder how I could incorporate full
wipe of a pool table where all the balls
are cleared off in one shot the perfect
shot and have that seamlessly Loop but
what I landed on was actually simulating
all of the balls falling into the seam
the first day working on this you know I
was riding High I got my pool table set
up it looked cool I got the balls
working I got the simulation working
where they all fell into place and I was
like wow this is going to be easy but
then came the part of actually having to
play Virtual pool and turns out I might
be better at pool in real life than I am
virtually because it got down to like
I'm I'm here I'm adjusting my pool cue
just like my tiny little you know
fractions decimal points because I had
to keyframe in you know the the pull
back of the queue to get the right power
perfectly lining it up with where this
lid a little piece of geometry
interacted with this ball and it turns
out that's really really hard so I did
simulate it it did hit and I got to the
point where this is all simulation it
hits this and this is where I started to
hand animate things because I could not
get them all in simulation supposed to
mimic reality and reality is hard
apology acceptance
mental health matters it does
I did end up getting to the point where
I was like okay I'm gonna cheat this a
little bit I'm gonna do some air bending
similar to my advice Jordan Allen on his
Challenge and it got me to a point where
I could actually get all of the balls
into the pockets and then just animating
so that it seamlessly Loops once the cue
ball bounces off the back and then that
sets us back to our first frame where it
then rolls into place and never actually
stops moving before it's hit and try to
blend the simulated parts of this scene
with the actual hand animated parts and
then I was like you know what though
it's like it's kind of boring if it's
just that and so I wanted to do some
like environmental storytelling so I got
a whole bunch of different assets I've
been watching last of us because the
show is absolutely amazing and I wanted
to do kind of like a what if there was
like a bar in the last of us so I did
this old looking pool table where I took
a bunch of different textures and mixed
materials together as if there's been
people just ripping up the green of the
pool table or revealing these boards
underneath all the broken up wood added
some beer bottles in here that you can
hardly even see in the final render but
they're there and they looked really
nice and and I just wanted to be like
all right what if like you were just
exploring some abandoned buildings in
The Last of Us and you happened to cross
a pool table
you might want to play with your buddies
so there's like stacks of dollar bills
and stuff as if someone you know was
placing some crazy bets right as the
apocalypse happened there's a nice
hunting knife shoved in the corner there
it's my favorite little part there's a
little little cigarette there and this
actually lights up in the scene and
there's I made a looping smoke element
so that once the loop of the scene
starts again that it's a seamless Loop
of this element there's little particles
as well throughout the scene kind of
spores last of us style those subtle
little atmospheric things you might not
see it at first but it it adds a little
bit to the story of like why is there
this beat up pool table that was kind of
my thought behind it was it's like what
would you do if you stumbled across a
pool table and you're like you know what
you don't need to find food we just
shoot some pool and you have to pull up
the the greatest shot of all time
hopefully Wes is uh
super satisfied oh hello there doctor
satisfaction At Your Service
this is kind of when I peaked like it
became the 23rd most liked video on the
entire Tick Tock platform it's hard for
me to not like just sit here and think
about this because like what made this
work so well what about this triggered
the viral gods and it's like yes this
will be what we Elevate to the people
and so I've been thinking about it
there's a lot going for it satisfying
sounds I think is incredibly important I
like the the sort of vibrant colors it's
a good looking image I think I've kind
of boiled it down to a few sort of like
nebulous elements that encourage this
sort of virality one of those being you
don't know that it looped I think it
tricked people into not knowing the
video had ended and so Tick Tock just
thinks wow everyone must really like
this video they just keep watching it so
that's like the primary thing I want to
bring to my new satisfying render so I
have an iPad app called procreate I love
this app I don't really have any sort of
traditional education when it comes to
painting or arts and stuff like that but
this has been an amazing way to practice
all that and so I've done a whole bunch
of stuff but one day I discovered that
you can just like make these lines of
fold colors like this and I could just
like keep going through here there's an
effect called liquify you can push stuff
around I can like create crystals and
stuff like that that's kind of cool but
there's another slider here called
Distortion and if I Max that out it
actually increases the number of swirls
that I do so literally all I have to do
and what's cool is that there's momentum
to it as well so like if I move it it'll
actually continue to swirl as if it's
being physically simulated and that's
key here it's what makes it look like
liquid I literally just sliced it up
exported it as an actual image sequence
that I could then import into Cinema 4D
as a texture so my goal for the actual
content of the satisfying render is to
combine the paint swirls with a swirling
cloth that disappears allowing a new
cloth to be painted on and then taken
out with a camera move that just goes
forever that's the goal I think I can do
it but first I gotta actually figure out
what my cloth simulation is gonna be so
I have this cloth sitting here on like a
board with a hole in it so my cloth here
is literally just a very very subdivided
plane tons of polygons but they're all
flat so by telling the program that this
is a cloth and then taking some of the
vertices of the cloth and pulling it
through a hole everything else should
just follow and
it kind of does look at this I mean
that's pretty satisfying so I was
digging this until I started realizing
it kind of has um
it's got a little bit of like
sphincture energy if you know what I
mean
this is a little bit butthole you know I
started panicking a little bit and it's
like is this satisfying I don't know
okay it's all right if it is I'm just
saying
so then I tried a different one where it
gets pulled through like a gutter so I
just took that and I slapped it on here
got a little hand that basically pulls
this cloth through this gutter in the
wall but the problem though is that it
wasn't checking that little box called
satisfaction it's not a satisfying shot
so then I went back to thinking about
that hole in the ground I was like what
if that was inverted like a vacuum
cleaner sucking up a clot
all right so this leads me to my third
render that I made the whole swirl is
happening here and what's cool is that
you can actually see it Clump up and
then the glass sucks it up okay this is
great so I've got the timing all spaced
out perfectly I've got the camera move
moving very consistently and linearly
across the wood texture ideally just add
in some lights get the camera move going
make sure that the actual wood texture
is exactly scaled so that the distance
the camera moves is one tile or multiple
of those tiles that's the secret to
making a shot that just looks like it's
moving forever making sure you're tiling
the matches we're a couple days away
from showing Wes this and I have to
satisfy him but this is shaping up to be
a multi-hundred frame render this might
be like 700 frames long I don't think
even overnight is going to be enough
time to render that fortunately I've
been using this service called render
token it's essentially cloud computing
for octane render but it's not in the
cloud it's like crypto rendering
well what if instead of mining Bitcoin
that computer was rendering shots for
you I think that's going to be my savior
for this video because I'm running out
of time to render this thing my time
actually has some value right now AKA I
really need to satisfy Wes
[Music]
so Wes here has already been sent the
renders that we have ready he is looking
through them right now and measuring his
own levels of satisfaction all right
Guys West couldn't make it the name's
the blast so let's start with banners
real quick okay oh he's picking them out
let's go let's go
thank you
oh
oh perfectly lined up
this is what every pool player dreams of
have happening I was really happy and
then the eight ball goes in last oh
you're so Advanced that is so satisfying
dude that sound of the break is just yes
yeah yeah so good it's really hard to
make a perfect pool shot
advice to me was to introduce wind in
order to make that shot and you did the
same thing you son of a gun I did
Welcome ball Benders we're ball vendors
that's what we do
there's fire air earth water and balls
and balls Captain Planet Peter's next
whoa whoa I don't know if I'm ready for
this no I'm ready
wait a minute wait a minute
what is this is it finally time I've
been waiting two years to be satisfied
by this I can't believe it is this
actually happening right now run the
tape
oh look at that guy
I remember this
I saw this before I even knew Peter
I can't believe it right now this is
remastered this is this is updated this
is this is
dude it's so good
Peter is that you yes dude
that's old man me oh menu Peter oh my
God bro Peter oh
my God
the perfect house oh and then the eyes
closed gosh wow just give it to Peter
great stuff although one of the criteria
was that I had to perfectly Loop right
where where is this criteria if this
criteria exists roll it back because I
don't believe it looping is a
requirement
honestly guys it represents the circle
of life so technically that's a loot
Circle okay circle of life circle of
life I'll take it Circle building a shed
so my thing that I was trying to do was
to make a looping video that you didn't
realize was looping
oh yeah
Ren welcome back to the top of tick tock
yeah
I just want to get sucked up
I mean hear me out what do you think was
it takes me back when I used to go to
theme parks and I have Slurpee I'd have
a fruit roll-up inside of there and I
just sucked the Fruit Roll-Up out yeah
that's good right no that's what I'm
talking about just the top of it just
like
oh I love it I literally had a pipe and
I had a ball attached to the cloth
underneath go animate up through the
thing
on the yeah the cloth there okay cool I
hope to satisfy I really do I'm sorry
for keeping you guys waiting I know I've
really pinched you up you're nice and
tight just the way I like it and uh
we're gonna loosen you up make it even
more exciting for you
oh
thank you
bro it was worth the wait
oh
it was worth the wait
that's how they make those lint
chocolate balls yeah yeah yeah dude this
is nice thank you brother so uh blash
didn't see it but you did man you had to
run I already I heard he's great I
already loved the whole show but I did I
liked it now that you've seen all four
satisfying renders who satisfied you the
most I'm looking for a few things I'm
looking for satisfaction and I'm looking
for emotion intention like what is this
are you guys bringing me into a story
but if I had to choose I feel like
[Music]
I had to go with Peter
let's go
wow
this is more meaningful to me than
anything in my life has ever been this
one was really fun to make it was
surprising opening up my old blender
files but then I opened it up and I was
like I gotta redo this because I can do
much better now and so I remade the
assets I remade the farmer completely
from scratch it's a 3D scan of my head
with a 3D model of the body and the arms
I did the hair on the Hedgehog again I
have new techniques I've learned over
the past couple years for that so it was
nice to kind of revisit the old work and
see how mediocre it was and now be able
to do it in a nicer way